اتابع محمد مع التطورات الميدانيه فقط
اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه عن مقتل
150 جنديا روسيا واصابه 50 في قصف لقواتها
على مطار لتجمع القوات الروسيه في كافكا
بمنطقه خرسون جنوب البلاد وقالت لينا
القصفه الاوكرانيه على المطار تسبب في
تدمير 20 واحده من المعادلات العسكريه من
مختلفه الوحدات في ميكولا
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه انها قصف
التجمعات الروسيه ما اسفر عن اصابتهم 140
جنديا روسيا وتدمي ثمانيه شاحنات ذخيره من
نوع كماس
اما على ضفتي النهري دنيتر فاكدت قياده
عمليته الجنوب الاوكرانيه استمرار القصف
المتبادل بالمدفعيه الثقيله واتهمت القوات
الروسيه بشان عشرات الهجمات الصاروخيه على
طول خطوط التماس بميكو لايف وزباروج
جنوبيه البلاد
معنى الان من ميكو لايف مراسل جزيره تامر
بلدي يمكن ان يضاف حول التطورات عموما
وخصوصا ايضا
بالتاكيد ازدهار في ميكو لايف القصف
يتواصل على المناطق الساحليه تحديدا في
منطقه تشوكو هذه المنطقه التي المليئه
بالتجمعات المائيه ويوم امس ايضا كان
هنالك قصف على الميناء النهري في الشوكو
ووقع وفقا للسرطان المحليه الاوكرانيه
هناك عدد من الجرح بينهم اطفال لكنها تطور
الاكبر اللافت الحقيقي وفقا لهيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه هو في خيرسون القصف الروسي
متواصل على عموم اقليم خرسان خلال الساعه
الاخيره تحدثت القياده العسكريه
الاوكرانيه عن اكثر من 60 هجوما للقوات
الروسيه على عموم المقاطعه وتحدثت ايضا عن
30 هجوما في همم وسط المدينه تحدثت عن قصف
للمواقع السكنيه
والمدارس لاحد المستشفيات في قلب المدينه
لكن في المقابل القصف والقذف المتبادل
بالم هيا الثقيله تشتد وتيرته على طول
ضفتين هاردينيبر خلال الساعات الاخيره
ايضا تحدثت هيئه الاركان عن مقتل 150 في
كفوفكا على الضفه الاخرى من النهر
للقوات الروسيه وتحديدا احد المطارات الذي
تتجمع في القوات الروسيه تحدثت ايضا عندما
في
العتاد الروسي هناك
وايضا في ذات الوقت تحدثت عن قصف اوكرانيه
يتواصل بالمدفعيه الثقيله على منطقه
نيكولا يفك في خير سون في الاضافه الى همم
هذه المنطقه المنطقه
لتواجد القوات الروسيه في هناك وتتحدث
القوات الاوكرانيه عن اصابه اكثر من 140
جنديا روسيا خلال الساعات الماضيه
بالاضافه الى تدمير عدد من الوحدات
العسكريه من مختلف الانواع نحن كنا
متواجدين يوم امس في خير في الحقيقه القصف
كان الاعن منذ ايام وهو لا يتوقف ويستمع
ويسمع اليه بشكل كثيف في زبروجيا
المواجهات مستعره بين الطرفين ايضا
عنوانها المدفعيه والمدفعيه المضاده قوه
الاوكرانيه تقصف تجمعات القوات الروسيه
وفقا للبيانات التي تصدر عنها تباعا في
منطقه ميليتوبيل مدينه ملتوبل في ريف
زباروجا الذي يسيطر عليه الجيش الروسي
الاضافه الى توك ماك وفي الدين برو وسط
جنوبي البلاد يتواصل القصف الروسي
بالمدفعيه كما تقول السلطات المحليه هناك
تحديدا على منطقه نيكوبل القريبه جغرافيه
من محطه الطاقه النوويه في زبرجيا نعم
محمد شكرا جزيلا لك تامر صماديه كنت معنا
من ميكولايت